[Applaus]
[Musik]
meine Lieben visualpolitik Zuschauer
morgen wird König Charles III Formel zum
offiziellen Staatsoberhaupt des
Vereinigten Königreichs gekrönt mit 74
Jahren ist er der älteste Mensch der den
britischen Thron je besteigen durfte ja
viele lange Jahre musste erwarten denn
die Regentschaft seine Mutter Elisabeth
II stellt ebenfalls einen Rekord da sie
war die längste der britischen
Geschichte und auch wenn ihr Sohn bei
weitem nicht ihre Popularität genießt
nur 42% der Briten hätten für ihn
gestimmt wenn Sie eine Wahl gehabt
hätten seine Krönungszeremonie wird
trotzdem viele Millionen Zuschauer in
aller Welt in ihren Bann ziehen die
globale Bedeutung der tonerfolge auf dem
britischen Inseln geht doch weit über
den Show Effekt hinaus schaust der
dritte wird damit auch der neue König
von 14 weiteren Ländern auf dem
amerikanischen Kontinent und in Ozeanien
darunter so wichtige Länder wie Kanada
und Australien aber halt da ist noch
viel mehr Charles ist auch das neue
Oberhaupt des Camembert einer
Dachorganisation von 56 souveränen
Staaten darunter unter anderem so
bevölkerungsreiche Länder wie Indien
Pakistan Malaysia Nigeria und Südafrika
deshalb schaut er bereits am 9 September
die ganze Welt auf den Buckingham Palace
die Erwartungen an die Rede des Königs
waren damals enorm
ituner
sonnenalletice
up hill the
constitutionals at the hardwarnation and
where love you Kingdom oh in the Roms
and Terence the world and whatever maybe
your background ob believes
you
Respekt and love in seiner Rede bemühte
sich Charles der dritte die Kontinuität
zu betonen also dass ich im Vergleich
zur Regentschaft seiner Mutter nichts
ändern werde
im Zeitalter der sozialen Medien ist ein
Hauptproblem jedoch dass er eben nicht
seine Mutter ist Elizabeth II war eine
Geliebte und weithin akzeptierte
Persönlichkeit und der neue König hat
wie soll ich sagen nicht dieselben
grundlegenden Eigenschaften hinzu kommt
dass ich seit letztem Jahr über den
britischen Inseln ein wahrer sozialer
Sturm zusammengebaut hat dank
jahrzehntelange Misswirtschaft und
brexit müssen die Briten herbe
Einkommens und Wohlstandsverluste
hinnehmen immer mehr rutschen in die
Armut ab grundlegende öffentliche
Dienste und Infrastruktur wie die
Gesundheitsversorgung oder das
Transportsystem sind weit unter
kontinental europäische Standard
abgerutscht und als ob das noch nicht
genug wäre das Land seit Monaten von
Streiks überzogen die Gesellschaft ist
so polarisiert wie schon lange nicht
mehr eine einigen Figur wäre also ultra
wichtig auch schon bemerkt und versucht
diese Lücke nun schnell zu füllen z.B
schon bei seiner Krönung mit einigen
recht Kontroversen Reformen
die Öffentlichkeit ist eingeladen
während der Krönung des Königs ihre
Treue zu schwören britische Untertanen
werden aufgefordert einen Chor aus
Millionen von Stimmen zu bilden und
einen Treuheit abzulegen während sie den
Gottesdienst verfolgen weitere neue
Elemente sind dass der König ein eigens
verfasstes Gebet vorträgt auf Englisch
walisisch schottisch gellisch und irisch
um das erreiche Erbe des Vereinigten
Königreichs zu würdigen außerdem werden
anglikanische Bischöfe für den
teilnehmen das Problem ist jedoch das
während dieser neue Treue von einigen
als schöne Idee die Menschen
einzubeziehen interpretiert wird andere
darin geradezu einen Angriff auf die
Demokratie sehen die Pläne die
Öffentlichkeit aufzufordern dem König
während der Krönung die Teufel schwören
sind beleidigend taktlos und eine
volksverachtende Geste in eine
Demokratie ist es das Staatsoberhaupt
das dem Volk die Träumen sollte nicht
umgekehrt Graham Smith Versprecher der
antimonarchistischen Bewegung Republic
dies ist übrigens nicht nur die Ansicht
der britischen Republikaner auch mit
anderen Staaten die unter die britische
Krone fallen ist man not very amused die
Frage lautet also was können wir von
Charles dem dritten wirklich erwarten
wie könnte sich dieser Führungswechsel
auf das Vereinigte Königreich aber vor
allem auf das Camembert und damit auf
den britischen Einfluss im allgemeinen
auswirken könnte seine Krönung gar das
Ende der Monarchie darstellen oder
zumindest einige der 14 anderen nominell
von der britischen Krone regierten
Länder dazu veranlassen zu normalen
Republiken zu werden heute werden wir
all diese Fragen beantworten und zwar
gleich nach einem wichtigen Hinweis des
Sponsors der dieses Video möglich
gemacht hat es geht um ein ziemlich
ernstes Thema Datenmissbrauch durch
sogenannte data Broker also datenmakler
die unsere persönlichen Daten über alles
abgreifen und danach nicht nur an
seriöse Unternehmen verkaufen sondern
auch an Betrüger diese Betrüger
bombardieren uns dann mit unerwünschten
Anrufen SMS und E-Mails oder versuchen
uns auszunehmen leider haben wir keine
Kontrolle darüber an wen unsere Daten
verkauft werden aber die data Broker
sind gesetzlich ja so verpflichtet
unsere Daten zu löschen wenn wir sie
dazu auffordern das Problem dabei es
gibt Tausende von ihnen auch ist diese
Antragsprozess absichtlich kompliziert
gestaltet deswegen resignieren viele
Menschen einfach und lassen den ganzen
Schmuck passiv über sich ergehen der
Sponsor dieses Videos in kogny bietet
genau dafür jedoch eine Lösung inkognit
übernimmt die Aufgabe bei den data
Brokern aufzuräumen und die Löschanträge
zu stellen um uns vor Betrugsversuchen
zu schützen du meldest dich einfach bei
ihnen kommen nie an beauftragt sie in
deinem Namen die Löschanträge
durchzusetzen und verfolgst dann bequem
auf einem übersichtlichen Dashboard wie
deine Daten nach und nach aus dem Netz
verschwinden ohne einen solchen Service
wäre es für einen normalen Menschen
gerade so unmöglich diese Anträge selbst
zu bearbeiten und sich vor Betrug zu
schützen also tu was gutes für deine
datenhygiene und schau dir in KODi über
den Link in der Videobeschreibung an
außerdem mit dem promo-politik der er
hättest du auch noch 60% Rabatte wenn du
zu den ersten 100 gehörst die nutzen und
falls Ihr uns etwas Nettes tun wollt
ebenfalls in der Videobeschreibung
findet ihr einen Spenden Link mit denen
ihr unsere Arbeit auf freiwilliger Basis
unterstützen können vielen Dank schon
mal im voraus und natürlich bei allen
die bereits gespendet haben so und nun
lasst uns schnell zur Beantwortung
unserer brennenden Fragen schreiten das
machen wir diese oft indem wir zunächst
einen kurzen Blick in die Geschichte
werfen aufgepasst
die schwarze Spinne
[Musik]
1917 wir befinden uns mitten im Ersten
Weltkrieg die Gotha bombardiert London
und nein hier hat sich kein Megaprojekt
über diesen schweren Bomber der
deutschen Luftwaffe in Script
eingeschlichen die Gotha sind deswegen
wichtig weil das britische Empire zu
dieser Zeit vom Haus Sachsen Coburg und
Gotha regiert wurde im Grunde handelt es
sich um eine Dynastie die Deutscher war
als das Frankfurter Würstchen wie ihr
euch vorstellen könnt waren die Briten
mitten im Krieg gegen Deutschland
darüber nicht very News diese ganze
verwandtschaftsgeschichte war einfach
unglaublich schlechte Pia für das
Königshaus und so erkannte König Georg
der 5 der Urgroßvater von schaust dem
dritten das sein eigenes Überleben und
die Zukunft seiner Familie als britische
Herrscher davon abhängt dass er auf alle
seine deutschen Titel verzichtete und
wie wir hier bei Visual Politik sagen
gesagt getan Leonard Raven Hill einen
Karikaturist der Zeitschrift Tanz
drückte es folgendermaßen aus auf diese
Weise wurde eine neue Dynastie geboren
die witzers sie gaben auf was sie
gewesen waren passen sich dem an was von
ihnen als monarchendes Empire erwartet
wurde und das ist vielleicht die beste
Lehre die Charles aus der Geschichte
seiner Familie ziehen konnte eine
einfache Lektion aber in der Praxis
überaus kompliziert umzusetzen wieder
Fall von Charles Großonkel zeigt etwa
der achte verzichtete auf den Thron
Umwelt Simpsons so heiraten damals eine
unmögliche Verbindung für einen
Monarchen weil die Damen nicht nur
Amerikanerin sondern vor allem eine
geschiedene Frau war doch zum Glück
stand in der Zwischenzeit ein großer
Meister des königlichen Handwerks als
Vorbild zur Verfügung
[Musik]
sieben Jahrzehnte lang übte Elizabeth II
das Amt der Königin mit großen Geschick
aus da sie die Kunst beherrschte viel zu
reden ohne etwas zu sagen konnte ihr in
diesen 70 Jahren niemand vorwerfen sie
habe ihre Pflicht zur Neutralität in der
öffentlichen Debatte verlässt nicht
einmal die schottischen Nationalisten
taten dies Eiskönigin Elisabeth vor dem
Unabhängigkeit von 2014 den Menschen im
Fall ihre Stimme gut zu überdenken
Charles ist seit 64 Jahren der Prinz von
Wales da er der ewige Erbe ist stand er
schon immer im Rampenlicht wir Wissen
praktisch alles über ihn vielleicht zu
viel und deshalb werden wir hier die
Seifenoper die wir seit 30 Jahren immer
wieder sehen nicht wieder aufwärmen
natürlich haben wir es hier mit einer
persönlichen Vergangenheit zu tun die
seinem öffentlichen Image oft geschadet
hat aber was anschafft wirklich auffällt
ist seine Neigung seine Meinung zu einer
Vielzahl von Themen zu äußern ein Trend
der sogar hin und wieder zu
diplomatischen Zwischenfällen geführt
hat wollte ein Beispiel nun seht euch
mal das ja an eine absichtliche
riskierung präzise dass das Paket mit
Präsident auslassen Charles ist ein
Unterstützer des Dalai Lama des
Geistlichen
in China als gefährlichen Separatisten
betrachtet China wurde von Charles noch
nie besonders Wohlwollen betrachtet erst
im August 2022 maßregelte er Peking das
es weniger die umweltverschmutzen müsste
damit der Kampf gegen den Klimawandel
erfolgreich sein können wir sprechen
also von einem Herrscher der als Prinz
immer sehr klare Ansichten hatte
[Musik]
zum Beispiel war die globale Erwärmung
immer eines der großen Anliegen des
Prince of Bales aber nicht das einzige
er ist auch ein starker Verfechter des
Recyclings und hat seit Jahrzehnten eine
eigene Marke für Bio-Lebensmittel ja die
Erhaltung des Ökosystems ist definitiv
eine Priorität für diesen Monarchen und
mit Ökosystem meinen wir sowohl die
Umwelt als auch die lokalen Traditionen
und die Kultur denn Charles hat sich in
jeder Hinsicht wahrlich weit aus dem
Fenster gelegt er hat sogar ein Projekt
zur Erweiterung der Nationalgalerie
angegriffen weil das vorgeschlagene
Gebäude für seinen Geschmack zum
modernen war schaut euch
[Musik]
anhaltend
und am Ende wurde dieses Projekt
tatsächlich nicht mehr weiter verfolgt
aber was Schatz betrifft ist ist klar
dass die Rolle des Grinsen nicht
dieselbe ist wie des Königs überlegt mal
wenn als König äußert dass ihm etwas
nicht gefällt dann gerät er im Gegensatz
zu uns Normalsterblichen direkt ins
Visier derjenigen die nicht derselben
Meinung sind und für die Winzers ist es
natürlich in Ihrem Interesse dass alle
Briten sie als ihre Monarchen anerkennen
also als ein Symbol des Staates
vergleichbar mit der Flagge und der
Hymne erteilt übergreifend deshalb
könnte es ein Problem werden wenn er
neue Monarch als Aktivist wahrgenommen
wird das war schon ein Problem als Prinz
Charles durch einen Medien Skandal als
schwarze Spinne bekannt wurde
[Musik]
die Black spider-memos sind eine Reihe
von Briefen die Prinz Charles anonym an
Premierminister und Kabinettsmitglieder
schrieb sie sind nach den krassereien
benannt mit denen Charles versuchte die
wichtigsten Themen die ihm am Herzen
lagen bei der Regierung hervorzuheben so
setzt er sich zum Beispiel gegen einen
von Toni bleph verfolgtes Verbot von
Fuchsjagd an einem Fall den Abschluss
von Dachsen zu Bekämpfung der
Rindertuberkulose freizugeben er wagte
es sogar sich in den Irak einzumischen
und kritisierte die von ihnen
wahrgenommenen Unzulänglichkeiten der
links Hubschrauber
die Wahrheit ist jedoch dass es nicht so
aussieht als würde Charles als König ein
Aktivist bleiben als Königin Elisabeth
älter wurde und Charles wusste dass
seine Thronbesteigung nur noch eine
Frage der Zeit war bei der ewige Erbe
bemüht das britische Volk zu beruhigen
er hat es selbst gesagt als er noch Erbe
war black Spider gehört der
Vergangenheit an ich denke es ist eine
Frage der Anreise geworden
[Musik]
ist das die Stunde für Charles König zu
sein in einem Alter gekommen ist in dem
andere Briten normalerweise irgendwo an
der Mittelmeerküste der Sonne nachjagen
es ist normal dass ein Erbe Zweifel
aufkommen lässt selbst wenn seine Rolle
in der Praxis Hupe grenzt ist Charles
weiß dass ihm viel weniger Zeit bleibt
als seiner Mutter und deswegen legt er
jetzt ein Affen Tempo auf dem Plan und
in diesem Fall könnte die lange Zeit die
als königslehrling hatte um sich gehörig
vorzubereiten sogar einen Vorteil
darstellen ja auf jeden Fall ist es
jetzt an ihm das Erbe seiner Mutter zu
verwalten und wenn ich von er bespreche
dann meine ich eine richtig richtig
großes Erbe Hörzu
[Musik]
ausgesorgt
zusätzlich zur Krone hinterließ
Elizabeth II ihren Sohn Charles ein
wahrlich saftiges Erbe das Herzogtum
Lancaster es geht um ein Portfolio von
Vermögenswerten Unternehmen Grundstücken
und Immobilien im Wert von rund 750
Millionen Dollar mit seiner Ernennung
zum Monarchen hat Charles jedoch das
Herzogtum Cornwall in Wert von mehr als
einer Milliarde Dollar allen sein Sohn
William den neuen Thronfolger
weitergegeben das britische Königshaus
kann wirklich nicht gerade als Abend
bezeichnet werden am interessantesten
ist vielleicht aber das unternehmerische
Profil seiner Finanzierung so werden z.B
die Gewinne die durch die Verwaltung
dieser Herzogtümer erzielt werden zur
Deckung der privaten Ausgaben der
Mitglieder der königlichen Familie
verwendet tatsächlich hat Charles auch
das Geld mit dem er all seine
wohltätigen Werke finanziert hat in
wesentlichen aus diesem Geldfluss
erhalten und dann wäre da natürlich noch
das eigentliche Juwel der Kohle das
sogenannte Crown ist Tate das auch etwa
20 Milliarden Dollar geschätzt wird
[Musik]
das Crown estate befindet sich aber
eigentlich im öffentlichen Besitz des
Staates dazu gehören übrigens die
Rennbahn Escort ein großer Teil des
Stadtzentrums von London und der
Meeresgrund Großbritanniens theoretisch
ist die Krone nämlich Eigentümerin all
dieser Ländereien tatsächlich werden sie
aber unabhängig von ihr durch eine
Gesellschaft verwaltet die der Regierung
unterstellt ist letztes Jahr betrunken
deren Gewinne etwa 350 Millionen Dollar
auf der Grundlage dieser Gewinne
wirklich staatliches Subvention des
Königshauses berechnet also das Geld
dass das Land in Winzer für ihre
Personalkosten reisen und die
Instandhaltung der Paläste gibt
um euch eine grobe Vorstellung zu geben
normalerweise erhält der Monat 15% der
Gewinn des Crown estate aus den
vergangenen zwei Jahren und die
britische Regierung behält den Rest es
wurde jedoch vereinbart was das
Königshaus zwischen 2017 und 2027 25%
erhält um den Buckingham Palace zu
renovieren das bedeutet dass sie in der
2 jahresperiode 2021/22 etwa 100
Millionen Dollar einstreichen Beträge
die in den Folgejahren möglicherweise
noch steigen werden denn das Crown ist
Tate ist eine regelrechte Geldmaschine
ehrlich gesagt ihr könnt euch kaum
vorstellen wie sehr der finanzielle Wind
zugunsten der Winzers weht und das nicht
nur im übertragenen Sinne Queen
Elizabeth verdient Millionen an den
Offshore Windparks in Großbritannien
auch wenn die staatlichen Subventionen
wieder auf 15% gedeckelt werden füllen
die offshore 8 Verträge für die
Errichtung von Windparks die königliche
Staatskasse auf hochto
[Musik]
und dann gibt es neben all diesen
Beträgen noch die sicherheitsausgaben
des Königshauses diese werden auf
weitere 100 Millionen Dollar geschätzt
und werden von der Metropolitan Police
getragen
König Charles Krönung kostet mehr als
250 Millionen Pfund der eine riesige
security-mission gestartet wurde ein
großer Teil rund 150 Millionen Pfund
wird für den Einsatz von tausenden von
Polizisten und Schutztruppen benötigt
der Rest wird für die Durchführung der
Zeremonie und die dreitägigen
Feierlichkeiten aufgewendet die
horrenden Kosten für die Steuerzahler
entstehen trotz des Wunsches des Königs
nach einer schlankeren kostengünstigeren
Monarchie es scheint jedoch das Charles
der dritte nun die Zahl der
Familienmitglieder die ihren
Amtshandlung teilnehmen reduzieren
möchte um diese haftige Rechnung etwas
zu entlasten die Frage ist jedoch wird
das ausreichen um die Gemüte der sozial
und finanziell immer mehr gebeutelten
Briten zu beschäftigen
wie reich ist König Charles Krönung löst
Prüfung des königlichen Reichtums aus
eine wachsende Minderheit in
Großbritannien betrachtet die königliche
Familie als ein teures Relikt Kritiker
vor allem junge Leute stellen ernsthaft
in Frage warum eine demokratische
Gesellschaft für die Alimentierung eines
Mannes mit einem symbolischen Job zahlt
sie ärgern sich darüber dass sie eine 40
prozentige Erbschaftssteuer zahlen
müssen während König Charles wird das
Vermögen dass er im letzten Jahr von
seiner Mutter geerbt hat und das
Hunderte von Millionen Dollar wert sein
sollten nichts bezahlt hat die
königliche Familie besitzt oder
profitiert von mehr als einem Prozent
des Grund und Bodens im Vereinigten
Königreich zum Vergleich die zehn
größten Landbesitzer in den Vereinigten
Staaten besitzen zusammen 0,7 % des
Landes diese Vermögenskonzentration ist
für manche angesichts der Krise der
Lebenshaltungskosten in Großbritannien
besonders ärgerlich vor allem wenn man
bedenkt dass der finanzielle Teil
vielleicht sogar die geringste von
Charles sorgen ist denn das Erbe seiner
Mutter hat auch einen großen Nachteil
ständig mit Elisabeth II verglichen zu
und das verspricht nicht leicht zu
werden
doch das Charts nicht die gleichen
Sympathien Weg wie Elisabeth wusste
sogar die ehemalige Königin selbst sehr
gut oder weil sie sich dessen bewusst
war setzte Elisabeth alles daran dass
ihr Sohn die höchste Ehre erhielt die
ihm international noch immer zu Teil
wird das Oberhaupt des Camemberts zu
sein im Gegensatz zu dem was viele Leute
denken gehört dieses Amt nämlich nicht
automatisch zum Titel des Monarchen des
Vereinigten Königreichs nein das
Oberhaupt des kammenwerft wird von dem
staatsoberhaltern alle Länder ernannt
die Mitglied in diesem besonderen Club
sind
tatsächlich wollte die Königin nicht
dass diese Frage nach ihrem Tod in der
Schwebe bleibt also hat sie 2018 dafür
gesorgt dass alles gut organisiert ist
er ist Charles wird das nächste
Oberhaupt des Camemberts
Staatsoberhäupter Ehren den Wunsch der
Königin und stimmen zu dass der Prinz
auf fails die Nachfolge der Monarchen
antritt und jetzt weiß ich was viele von
euch denken sag mal mal dieses Camembert
denke ist das nicht so etwas wie der
Schatten des britischen Empire etwas
dass die Briten erfunden haben um die
Vormundschaft über ihre ehemaligen
Kolonien zu behalten
[Musik]
nun vielleicht ist es das was London zu
vermitteln versucht aber in Wirklichkeit
ist es eine internationale Organisation
wie jede andere tatsächlich sind Länder
wie Gabun muss am Weg Ruanda und Togo
die keine historischen Bindungen zu
Vereinigten Königreich haben derzeit
nicht wieder das kamen Werft offiziell
verfolgt diese Organisation zwei Ziele
die Stärkung der Demokratie unter ihren
Mitgliedern und die Förderung der
wirtschaftlichen Entwicklung das Problem
ist jedoch das Charts von Hause aus
weder über den nötigen Einfluss verfügt
um ersteres zu erreichen also die
Demokratisierung noch hat er das Geld um
bei letzterem also der wirtschaftlichen
Entwicklung etwas zu bewegen einige
brexit Befürworter versuchen das kann
man Welt als Alternative zur
Europäischen Union darzustellen aber es
ist klar dass wir über völlig
unterschiedliche Dinge reden tatsächlich
gibt es sogar einige die an der Zukunft
diese Organisation zweifeln vor allem
jetzt wo die Königin nicht mehr lebt und
das Vereinigte Königreich momentan nicht
seine besten Tage zu haben scheint
dieses Szenario zu vermeiden und das
kann man nur so stärken oder die erste
Herausforderung für den neuen König es
geht um nichts Geringeres als die
internationale Rolle der Winzer und vor
allem um einen großen Teil des
britischen Einflusses ist aber das ist
nicht die einzige Herausforderung die
vor Charles liegt eine wahrscheinlichere
Krise besteht darin dass einige der 15
Länder in denen die Winzers noch
nominell an der Spitze des Staates
stehen versuchen werden Republiken zu
werden über welche Länder die hier
sprechen genau das schauen wir uns jetzt
an
neue Republiken am Horizont
wenn einige der sogenannten
commonwealtkönigreiche zu Republik
werden sollten kann man Charles
natürlich nicht die ganze Schuld daran
geben Elizabeth selbst erlebte wie sich
ganze 15 Länder während ihrer
Regierungszeit zu diesen Schritt
entschlossen haben wir sprechen hier von
Ländern wie Pakistan Südafrika Nigeria
Malta Vici Mauritius und Barbados
letzteres Rihannas Heimatland wurde im
November 2021 zur Republik und hey im
Interesse der Normalität war bei der
Zeremonie auch der damalige Prinz
Charles anwesend eine Abschaffung der
Monarchie läuft heutzutage friedlich und
vergleichsweise langweilig ab ganz ohne
Revolutionen und giotinen aber von den
derzeit 15 Karneval Königreichen gibt es
eines das eine besondere Abneigung gegen
seinen neuen König hegt habt ihr eine
Idee welches ich meine nun sieht euch
mal folgendes an aus einem Brief geht
hervor das Prinz Charles die umstrittene
Entlassung des australischen trainieren
ist das unterstützte dieser Brief kam
2020 an s Licht und bezieht sich auf
eine der dunkelsten Episoden der
australischen Geschichte die
Verfassungskrise von 1975
damals ersetzte der generalgewinner von
Australien also der Vertreter der
britischen Monarchie der mit der
Ausübung der Funktion des
Staatsoberhaupts betraut ist in
Premierminister der Leber geführten
Regierung Australiens einfach ab die
Regierung erlebte nämlich eine Phase
tiefgreifende Schwäche und der
generalgewinner setzte ihr einfach mit
einem widerstrich ein Ende er ernannte
den Oppositionsführer zum
Premierminister und leitete eine
achtjährige Koalitionsregierung zwischen
Liberalen und konservativen ein
natürlich dementierte das britische
Königshaus damals jegliche Einmischung
in diese inne australische Angelegenheit
viele Australier hickten jedoch einen
finsteren Verdacht und waren der Meinung
dass der generalgewöhner mit dieser
Aktion seine Befugnisse drastisch
überschritten hatte und diese
Wahrnehmung in der Bevölkerung löste
eine starke republikanische Stimmung aus
tja und im Jahr 1999 bekamen die
Republikaner ihre Chance die
australische Nation hielt ein Referendum
ab um eine Republik zu werden aber der
Versuch scheiterte an einer Ablehnung
von 60% der Bevölkerung doch zwei
Jahrzehnte später hat Veröffentlichung
dieser privaten Korrespondenz die darauf
hindeutet dass die britische Monarchie
doch erheblichen Einfluss auf die
australische Politik ausübte den
republikanischen Block der seit einigen
Jahren in Umfragen führend ist neue
Argumente geliefert tatsächlich waren
die Befürworter des monarchischen
Systems bis 2021 auf 28% gefallen
das platinjubiläum der Königin und all
die Ehrungen nach ihrem Tod scheinen die
Dinge jedoch wieder ins Gleichgewicht
gebracht zu haben die Frage ist handelt
es sich um eine Art champagner-effekt
nun im Moment scheint es jedenfalls
unwahrscheinlich dass die australischen
Republikaner ihr Ziel kurzfristig
erreichen werden da sie neben einer
Mehrheit auf nationaler Ebene auch eine
Mehrheit mindestens 4 der 6
australischen Bundesstaaten erreichen
müssten ein ähnlicher Prozess wie
Australien verzieht sich gerade in
Kanada doch wenn dieses Land die
Monarchie abschaffen wollte bräuchte es
die sogenannte eigenständige Zustimmung
das heißt nicht weniger als eine
Mehrheit im Unterhaus im Senat und in
den zehn Provinz Parlamenten von der
formellen Umsetzbarkeit her wäre es also
selbst für die Briten leichte die
Winters aus den Buckingham Palace zu
werfen als wir die Kanada die er sich
für eine Republik zu entscheiden aber
andere Länder hätten es darf viele
leichter
in Neuseeland zum Beispiel würde ein
einfacher Parlamentsbeschluss ausreichen
um die Monarchie abzuschaffen aber die
ehemalige Premierministerin Jessica
Arden schloss eine zeitnah Abschaffung
der Monarchie öffentlich aus und ihr
Nachfolger chris hippkins hat bisher
noch keine Anzeichen gezeigt
diesbezüglich andere Pläne zu verfolgen
auch viele karibische Länder könnten
ohne eine Referendum Republiken werden
in der Vergangenheit haben jedoch
mehrere Staaten ihr Versprechen dies zu
tun nicht erfüllt wie z.B Jamaika 2009
fand auf St Vincent und international
eine Referendum über die Republik statt
das genauso scheiterte wie ein Jahr
zuvor auf Barbados im letzteren Fall
entschied sich jedoch schließlich dafür
durch eine Verfassungsänderung die von
einer 2/3 Mehrheit des Parlaments
angenommen wurde eine Republik zu werden
und ich bin mir sicher dass ich einige
von euch fragen was ist mit
Großbritannien wie stark sind doch der
Republikaner nun die Wahrheit ist das
die Unterstützung für die
parlamentarische Monarchie bisher bei
drei zu eins
[Musik]
die Figur des Monarchen ist die am
meisten respektierte Institution im
Vereinten Königreich denn die wir alle
bereits wissen wenn es etwas gibt das
das britische Volk enttäuscht dann sind
es seine Politiker oder wenn wir ganz
ehrlich sind ihr Essen und außerdem
sollten wir nicht vergessen dass das
Königshaus trotz aller Einschränkungen
immer noch ein mächtiger Mechanismus für
internationalen Einfluss ist schließlich
ist es nicht schlechter Staatsoberhaupt
mit Australien Kanada und Neuseeland zu
teilen um die politischen sozialen
kulturellen und wirtschaftlichen
Beziehungen aufrecht zu erhalten
tatsächlich könnte genau dies nach dem
brexit die größte Rolle des Königshauses
werden und im Moment ist es wahrlich
keine Kleinigkeit des Oberhaupt des
kammenwerfers zu sein letzten Endes
handelt die Regierung also macht
politisch richtig wenn Sie die Monarchie
schützt und die frühere Premierminister
hat keine Minute gezögert um zu
verhindern dass schaffst der dritte
erneut in Versuchung gerät zur schwarzen
Spinne zu werden König Charles wird auf
Anraten von Trassen nicht am Klima
Gipfel teilnehmen schade dass die
Premierministerin nicht so fleißig war
was ihre eigenen Angelegenheiten anging
aber darüber haben wir uns hier auf
visualer Politik ja schon ausgiebig
ausgelassen daher also jetzt die Frage
an euch denkt ihr das schaust der dritte
ein guter König sein wird glaubt ihr
dass viele commonwealtkönigreiche
versuchen werden Republiken zu werden
wenn eine solche Ikone wie Elisabeth II
nicht mehr da ist welche Rolle wird der
neue Monarch in der internationalen
Politik des vereinten Königreichs nach
dem brexit Spiel spielen wie immer sind
auf eure Diskussionsbeiträge zu diesem
Thema schon mächtig gespannt ich hoffe
dass euch dieses Video gefallen hat und
vielleicht auch was dabei gelernt habt
falls ja gibt uns bitte ein Leid Freunde
und vergesslich das Abo mit Glocke
keines unserer Videos mehr zu verpassen
natürlich freuen uns auch jederzeit über
eine Spende von euch dieses Projekt
weiterzuführen und den Link dazu findet
ihr in der Beschreibung unter dem Video
macht's gut und bis bald
[Musik]